so there'll be no spectators at olympic
events in
tokyo the organizing committee made the
decision after japan declared a state of
emergency in the capital
as coronavirus cases their surge the
policy for venues outside tokyo will be
decided on a case-by-case basis
medical experts have criticized plans to
go ahead with the games
the government and organizers say
they're doing everything they can to
ensure
safe olympic and paralympic games
without the pandemic the olympic games
would be an amazing opportunity to unite
people
but unfortunately the pandemic could not
allow us to hold events with full
spectators
we are very sorry for the locals living
near the olympic venues
peter semet our sports presenter joins
us now on the program
um two weeks to go before the olympics
start this was kind of
expected what impact is it going to have
though on athletes
and their performances yeah fairly quite
right it was expected i think we all saw
this coming what impact is it going to
have well i think from an athlete's
point of view
consider that they train not just for
four years between olympics but many of
them they've been training for their
whole lives for this moment
and you would want to think that winning
a medal whether it be gold silver or
bronze it's the kind of thing that you
you enjoy in front of a crowd especially
in athletics and swimming
um some of the other sports as well but
especially those two those are the two
flagship events at the olympic games
80 000 people or in the swimming arena
maybe 15 000 people
cheering your name perhaps and that is
gone
that will not be at tokyo 2020. but for
some of the events it doesn't really
make a difference does it events like
fencing
yeah exactly i mean there are certain
sports which are a lot smaller
more niche you know the kind of things
that only really get attention every
four years and in between
i don't want to say nobody cares but it
doesn't get the kind of attention that
that that it would perhaps like to have
fencing being a very good example of
that
and in those cases while the athletes
are actually
uh playing or competing the crowd is
expected to keep quiet so
you know from an atmosphere point of
view doesn't really make a difference
but again once it's all done
and medals are being handed out you'd
like to get an applause or indeed
from from the crowd that's not going to
be happening india the japanese olympic
committee president has apologized to to
people who've bought their tickets
already
what impact is this going to have
financially on revenue i imagine
it's going to be costly for japan well
it's going to hit them it's not going to
hit the international olympic committee
because the irc
already has its money from broadcasting
and sponsorships
between the two of them you're looking
at around 15 to 18 billion dollars
however the ticket sales that is where
the japanese organizing committee loses
its money you're looking at anything up
to around 800 to 900
million dollars and that unfortunately
is going to have to be paid by the
japanese taxpayer
peter thank you very much for that now
earlier i spoke to
dan olowitz who's a sports writer with
the japan times he says the announcement
is hugely disappointing for olympic fans
and for
japan as a whole this was supposed to be
our shining moment uh this was supposed
to be a
a huge moment for uh for tokyo
for japan uh so much effort has gone
into preparing
uh the capital to host these games uh
the infrastructure
uh the emphasis on improving service for
inbound tourists uh everything uh
that has changed in the city over the
last decade has been uh
in anticipation of these olympics and
now it's going to be
a lot of empty stadiums i think that uh
holding this without
holding the games without fans is the
easiest
way for organizers to get this event
across the finish line
uh just like the runners just like every
other competitor at the games uh with
uh minimal risk to the health and safety
of the athletes
and all other participants uh
by taking away the fans you're reducing
the need for staffing you're reducing
the number of volunteers who need to be
on site
and you're reducing the strain on the
public transit system
it makes sense just from a logistical
perspective but obviously these aren't
going to be
games uh that are it's not going to
create a sense of excitement you're not
going to have the festival atmosphere
that we've seen
in rio in london uh in
in beijing in athens before that so
it is really disappointing